thank you / so thank you cool so you
guys this is awesome I've been watching
the lectures in this course isn't it
absolutely amazing good content and now
you're stuck with me
so unlike Paul when he was talking in
the Q&A and you guys asked him what he'd
do if he was a college today and he said
physics I actually indulged myself I
went and I went and did physics did
physics at Cambridge and I think physics
is an amazing class to give you
transferable skills that are really
useful in other areas but I guess that's
not that's not why you're listening to
me today like physics isn't the class
like so I paid for college doing online
marketing direct response marketing I
started with SEO in the 1990s I created
a paper airplane site
I had a monopoly in the small niche
market of paper airplanes globally which
you know when you want to start a
startup also see how big the market
could be in the long term it wasn't
great but what that taught me was how to
do SEO and back in those days it was out
to Vista and the way to do SEO is to
have white text on a white background
five pages below the fold and you would
rank top of Alta Vista if you just said
paper airplanes 20 or 30 times in that
text and that was how you want an SEO in
the 1990s like it was a really easy easy
skill to learn when I went to college
being a physicist I thought paper
airplanes would make me cool and I was
actually the most nerdy person in the
physics class so I created a cocktail
site which was how I learnt to program
and that grew to be largest cocktail
site in the UK and that really got me
into SEO properly when GUI launched so
with Google you had to worry about
PageRank and you had to worry about
getting links back to your site which
basically at that stage meant one link
from the Yahoo directory got you to the
top listing in Google if you had white
text on a white background below the
fold as well when Google launched
AdWords that's when I really started to
learn how to do on my marketing and that
was buying paid clicks from Google and
reselling them to eBay for a small
margin of like 20% using their affiliate
program and that was what really kicked
me until I would drive into doing what
everyone nowadays talks about its growth
or growth hacking or growth marketing
and in my mind is just internet
marketing using whatever channel you can
to get whatever output you want
that's how I paid for college and how I
ended up going from being a physicist to
marketer and transitioning to the dark
side of the force so what do you think
matters most for growth you've had loads
of lectures and people have said it over
and over so what do you guys think
matters most for growth someone give me
an answer are you brother
great product I agree great product what
is great product lead to customers and
what do you need those customers to do
spread the word
someone said stay on your site someone
sent package that's it retention
retention is the single most important
thing for growth now we have an awesome
growth team at Facebook and I'm super
proud to work on it but the truth of the
matter is we have a fantastic product
but getting to work on growth of
Facebook is a massive privilege because
we're promoting something that everyone
in the world really wants to use which
is absolutely incredible if we can get
people on and get them ramped up they
stick on Facebook so many times like
I've advised multiple startups my
favorite was working with Airbnb but
with Coursera I've worked with other
ones that haven't done as well as those
guys but the one thing that is true over
and over and over again is if you look
at this curve the cent monthly active
versus number of days from acquisition
if you end up with a retention curve
that asymptotes to a line parallel to
the x-axis you have a viable business
and you have product market fit for some
subset of market but most of the
companies that you see fly up who talk
about growth hacking and virality and
all of this other stuff in a trice so
hard not to swear but it'll happen their
retention curve slopes down towards the
x-axis and in the end intercepts the
x-axis now when I show this chart to
most people they say that's all well and
good you had a million people a day in
terms of growth when you started the
growth team at Facebook or you were at
50 million users you had a lot of people
joining sites so you had a ton of data
to do this we use the same methodology
for our b2b growth getting people to
sign up as self-service advertisers we
used this analysis to understand how
much growth we were going to have in
that market as well and in
place when I joined Facebook the product
was three days old and within 90 days of
the product launching we were able to
use this technique to be able to figure
out what the one-year value of an
advertiser was and we predicted it for a
full of the first year to 97% of what
the number turned out to be so I think
it's very important to look your
attention curve and this is how we did
it if you see here this red line is
number of users who have been on your
product for a certain number of days so
a bunch of people that should say Sarah
but a bunch of people will have been on
the product all of your users will have
been on at least one day but if your
products been around a year or whatever
you will have zero users who've been on
it 366 days make sense a curve sensible
cool so what you then do is look for all
of your users who have been on your
product one day what percentage of them
a monthly active hundred percent for the
first 30 days obviously because monthly
active they all signed up on one day but
then you look at thirty-one every single
user on their 31st day after
registration what percentage of them
were monthly active thirty second day
thirty third day thirty fourth day and
that allows you with only something like
ten thousand customers or whatever to
get a real idea of what this curve is
gonna look like for your product and
you're going to be able to tell does it
asymptote and it'll get noisy out
towards the right-hand side like I'm not
using real data it'll get noisy out
towards the right-hand side but you'll
be able to get a handle on does this
curve flatten out or does it not if it
doesn't flatten out don't go and do
growth tactics go and do virality don't
hire a growth hacker focus on getting
product market fit because in the end as
Sam said at the beginning this course
idea product team execution if you don't
have a great product there's no point
executing well on growing it because it
won't grow number one problem I've seen
inside Facebook for new products number
one problem I've seen for a startups
I've advised has been they don't
actually have product market fit when
they think they do so the next obvious
question that people ask over and over
and over again is okay what does good
retention look like sure I can have five
percent retention but I'm guessing that
Facebook had better than that so that's
not going to be a successful business
I get really pissed off when people ask
me that question because I think you can
figure it out and I love this story and
this is like my one gratuitous story
that I love that I'm throwing in here so
the rest of it may not be as gratuitous
but this is a picture that was published
in Life magazine in 1950 of one of the
Trinity nuclear bomb tests and there's a
guy Jeffrey Taylor who's heard of
Jeffrey Taylor awesome yes
someone's heard of him Jeffrey Taylor
was a British physicist who ended up
actually winning the Nobel Prize and he
was able to figure out from looking at
this picture what the power of the
atomic bomb was the u.s. atomic bomb and
Russians were publishing similar
pictures just using dimensional
reasoning and dimensional reasoning is I
think one of the best skills that I
learned during my time studying physics
back in the UK and what dimensional
reasoning is is you look at the
dimensions that are involved in a
problem so you want to figure out energy
Newton's meters Newtons are kilograms
meters seconds to minus two so you've
got kilograms meters squared seconds two
minus two and then you try and figure
out how you can get each of those
numbers from what data you have so the
mass is the volume of this sphere so
that's a meter cubed you throw in there
so you've got meters the five over
seconds to the minus two and he was able
to use that to just figure out what the
power of this atomic bomb was what the
ratios of the power were between the
Russian and US atomic bomb and
essentially reveal one of the top
secrets that existed in the world at
that time
that's a hard problem figuring out what
Facebook's retention rate is is not a
hard problem how many people are there
on the Internet give or take someone
throw something out 2.4 billion 2.3
billion something like that right
okay Facebook's banned in China so what
now about two billion two billion so two
billion people on the internet Facebook
in our last earning school said
something around 1.3 billion in terms of
number of active users you can divide
those numbers by each other and yeah
that won't give you the right answer of
course it's not gonna give you the right
answer but it's going to give you close
enough to a ballpark figure
of what the retention rate looks like
for Facebook if we've signed everyone on
the Internet up and then you will know
it's higher than that
similarly if you
look at what's that they've announced
600 million active users how many people
have smartphones you can figure out that
number that numbers out and knocking
around it can give you an idea of how
many users there are Amazon has had a
pop at signing up almost everyone in the
United States you know how many people
are online in the US and you've got a
good idea of how many customers Amazon
are from the numbers they throw out
different verticals need different
terminal retention rates for them to
have successful businesses if you're in
e-commerce and you're retaining on a
monthly active basis like 20 30 percent
of your users you're probably going to
do pretty well if you're in social media
and your first batch of people signing
up to your product are not like 80
percent retained you're not going to
have a massive social media site and so
it really depends on the vertical you're
in what the retention rates are what you
need to do is have the tools to think
about who out there is comparable and
how you can look at it and say am i
anywhere close to what real success
looks like in this vertical so retention
is the single most important thing for
growth and retention comes from having a
great idea and a great product to back
up that idea and great product market
fit the way we look at whether a product
has great retention or not is whether or
not the users who install it actually
stay on it long term when you normalize
on a cohort basis and I think that's a
really good methodology for looking at
your product and saying okay the first
hundred the first thousand the first ten
thousand people I get on this will they
be retained in the long run so now how
do you attack operating for growth let's
say you have awesome product market fit
you have built an e-commerce site and
you have 60 percent of people coming
back every single month and making a
purchase from you which would be
absolutely fantastic how do you then
take that and say now it's time to scale
now it's time to execute was the last
thing in your fault right and that's
where I think growth teams come in like
my contrarian viewpoint or whatever is
if you're a startup you shouldn't have a
[ __ ] growth
you shouldn't have a growth team halfway
through an ad I failed you shouldn't
have a growth team start
should not have growth teams the whole
company should be the growth team the
CEO should be the head of growth you
need someone to set a Northstar for you
Richards a shot of live you know Massa
Paige you need someone to set a
Northstar for you about where the
company wants to go and that person
needs to be the person leading the
company in my opinion from what I've
seen and Mark is a fantastic example of
that back when Facebook started lots of
people are putting out their registered
user numbers right you'd see registered
user numbers for MySpace you'd see
register use numbers for contact you can
see registered user numbers mark put out
monthly active users as the number both
internally he held everyone to to and
said we need everyone on Facebook but
that means everyone active on Facebook
not everyone signed up to Facebook so
monthly active people was the number
internally and it was also the number he
published externally it was the number
he made the whole world hold Facebook to
as the number that we cared about if you
look at what Yan has done with whatsapp
I think it's another great example he
always published send numbers if you're
a messaging application sends is
probably the single most important
number if people use you once a day
maybe that's great but they send one
message there you're not really their
primary messaging mechanism so yan
published the sends number right inside
air B&B they talk about nights booked
and they also publish that in all of the
like infographics that you see inside
TechCrunch they always benchmark
themselves against how many nights book
they have compared to the largest hotel
chains in the world they have each of
these companies a different North Star
the North Star doesn't have to be
monthly active users for every different
vertical for eBay when I was there it
was gross merchandise volume how much
stuff did people actually buy through
eBay everyone externally tends to judge
eBay based on revenue actually Benedict
Evans has done this amazing breakdown of
Amazon's business which is really
interesting to look at their marketplace
business versus their direct business
eBay is all marketplace business right
so eBay is being judged by its revenue
when actually has ten times or whatever
more gross merchandise volume going
through the site and that was the number
that eBay looked at when I was inside
there and optimized for so every
different come
when it thinks about growth needs a
different North Star but when you are
operating for growth it is critical that
you have that North Star and you define
it as a leader the reason this matters
is the second you have more than one
person working on anything you cannot
control what everyone else is doing
right I promise you having now hit a
hundred people I'm managing I I like
have no control it's all influence yes I
can say to one person do this one thing
but then the other 99 are gonna do
whatever the hell they want and the
thing is it's not clear to everybody
what the most important thing is for a
company it would be very easy inside
eBay for people to say you know what we
should focus on revenue or you know what
we should focus on the number of people
buying from us or you know what we
should focus on how many people list
items on eBay and Pierre and Meg and
John those guys as various leaders
always said no it's the amount of gross
merchandise volume that goes through our
site it's the percentage of e-commerce
that goes through our site that is what
really matters for this company which
means when people are having a
conversation you're not in a room or
when they're sitting in front of their
computer screen and thinking about how
they build this particular product or
this particular feature in their head
it's gonna be clear to them that it's
not about revenue it's about gross
merchandise volume or it's not about
getting more registrations registrations
don't matter unless they become
long-term active users a great example
of this was when I was at eBay in 2004
we changed the way we paid our
affiliates for new users and affiliate
programs are a bit out of fashion these
days but the idea of an affiliate
program is essentially you pay anyone on
the internet a referral for sending
traffic to your site but it's mostly
about getting access to like big
marketers who do it on their own I
accept it in some really good stories
honest we were paying for confirmed
registered users so all of our
affiliates were aligned they aren't
getting confirmed registered users to
the eBay site we changed our payment
model to pay for activated confirmed
registered users so you had to confirm
your account and then bid on an item or
buy an item or list an item
to become someone that we paid for
overnight when we made that change we
lost something like 20% of confirmed
registered users that were being driven
by the affiliates but the AC I use only
dropped by about 5% the ratio of CI you
to a CI you went up and then the growth
of a CI use massively accelerated the
cause of this was if you want to drive
CI use if someone searches for a
trampoline you land them on the
registration page because they think
they have to register and confirm before
they get that trampoline if you want to
drive AC I use you land them on the
search results page within eBay for
trampolines so they can see the thing
they want to buy get excited about it
and register when they want to buy it
and if you drive just see I use people
don't have an amazing magic moment on
eBay when they visit the site and that's
the next most important thing to think
about is how do you drive towards the
magic moment that gets people hooked on
your service so in the lecture notes for
this course I've stuck in a bunch of
links to people I think are brilliant at
all of this stuff that retention curve I
showed earlier there's a link to this
guy Danny Ferrante who's incredible
talking about retention curves the magic
moment there are two videos linked one
is shamov talking about growth who was
the guy who set up the growth team at
Facebook and one is my friend Naomi and
I talking at f8 four years ago about how
we were thinking about growth back then
and in both of those men both of those
videos we talked about the magic moment
so what do you guys think the magic
moment is for when you're signing up to
Facebook you hit that big green button
what is the moment when users are like
aha mark even talked about it at the
startup school a few years back you see
your friends simple as that
and usually it is very simple I talk to
so many companies and they try and get
incredibly complicated about what
they're doing but it is as simple as
just when you see that first picture of
one of your friends on Facebook you go
oh my god this is what the site is about
and Zach's talked at Y Combinator about
getting people to 10 friends in 14 days
that is why we focus on that metric the
number one most important thing in a
social media site is connecting to your
friends because without that you have a
complete
empty newsfeed and clearly you're not
going to come back you'll never get any
notifications you'll never have any
friends telling you about things they're
missing on the site so for Facebook the
magic moment is that moment when you see
your friends face and everything we do
on growth and if you look at the
LinkedIn registration flow you look at
the Twitter registration flow or you
look at what whatsapp does when you sign
up the number one thing all these
services look to do is to show you the
people you want to follow connect to
send messages to as quickly as possible
because in this vertical that's what
matters
when you think about Airbnb or you think
about eBay it's finding on eBay that
unique item that PEZ dispenser or broken
laser pointer that you really really
cared about and wanted to get hold of
like when you see that collectible thing
that you were missing that is the real
magic moment on eBay when you look on
Airbnb and you find that first you find
that that first listing that's like a
cool house that you can stay in and when
you go through the door that's a magic
moment and similarly on the other side
when you're listing your house the first
time you get paid is an amazing moment
when you're listing an item on eBay the
first time you get paid is a magic
moment you should ask Brian what he
thinks cuz they've done these amazing
storyboards which I think has been
shared of like the journey through a
users moment or a life on Airbnb and how
excited isn't he's talking in like three
lectures time the guy's awesome talking
about the magic moment and getting his
users to feel love and joy and all this
stuff so think about what the magic
moment is for your product and get
people connected to it as fast as
possible because then you can move up
where that blue line has asymptotes it
then you can go from 50% retention to
60% retention to 70 percent retention
easily if you can connect people with
the thing that makes them stick on your
site the second thing to think about is
everyone in the valley gets wrong that
we optimized when we think about growth
for ourselves so my favorite example is
notifications again talk to lots of
companies advice lots of companies every
single company when they talk about
notifications goes oh I'm getting too
many notifications I think that's what
we need to optimize for our
notifications okay are your power users
leaving your site because as they're
getting too many notifications no then
why would you optimize that they're
probably grownups and they can use
filters what you need to
focus on is the marginal user the one
person who doesn't get a notification in
a given day or month or year our
experience of our products and by the
way like building an awesome product is
all about thinking about the power user
right building an incredible product is
definitely optimizing for the people who
use your product the most but driving
growth people who are already using your
product all the time and not the ones
you have to worry about
so in this Danny Ferrante video there's
also that's linked from the lecture page
there's also talk about our growth
accounting framework that we used to
think about for growth and we looked at
new users resurrected users people who
weren't on Facebook for 30 days and came
back and churned users and the
resurrected and churn numbers for pretty
much every product I've ever seen
dominate the new user count once you
reach a sensible point of growth a
couple of years in whatever and all
those users who are churning and
resurrecting had low friend counts and
didn't find their friends and so weren't
connected to the great stuff that was
going on on Facebook and so the number
one thing we needed to focus on was
getting them to those ten friends
getting them to whatever number of
friends they needed so think about the
user on the margin don't think about
where yourself when you're thinking
about growth so operating for growth
what you really need to think about is
what is the North Star of your company
what is the one metric where if everyone
in the company is thinking about it and
driving their product towards that
metric and their actions towards moving
that metric up you know in the long run
your company will be successful and by
the way they're probably all correlated
to each other so it's fine to pick
almost any metric whichever one is like
the deepest like the you feel the best
about that aligns with like your mission
and your values probably go for that one
but realistically daily active users
fairly correlated to monthly active
users we could have gone with either one
amount of content shared also very
correlated to how many users there are
because guess what you add a user they
share content so lots of things end up
being correlated pick the one that fits
with you and that you know you're gonna
be able to stick with for a long time
but have a North Star have a North Star
and know the magic moment that when a
user experience is that they will
deliver on that metric for you on the
North Star and then think about the
marginal user don't think about yourself
those are I think the really important
points when you're operating for growth
everything has to come from the top so
the last area here is tactics and my
hope was that I could hit a few of these
and then I've got a list of tactics I
want to go through that I'm better
talking with a white board and whatever
on but you can ask me questions as I'm
going through on those about how they
work and what goes better
but the important tactics that you need
to think about
ah this is great guy by the way Tom
Fishburne he looked he lives in the Bay
Area and he does these really cynical
cartoons that I love so let's say you've
found your niche market that you're
gonna have a monopoly on inside the
mousetrap market it's a silenced
mousetrap for sitting under beds so that
if the mice come to your bed overnight
like they can be killed without waking
you up so that's your niche market and
your your mousetrap is better than
anybody else for that market what
typically happens in Silicon Valley is
everyone think mark thinks market is a
useless like I thought marketers were
useless when I was a physics student so
I'm sure as engineering students you
must think we're awful awful people who
aren't useful to have around like build
it and they will come that is something
that is very much the mantra in the
valley and I don't believe it's true I
believe you actually have to work
there's a good article again in the
lecture page from interviewing Ben
Silverman we talked about how the growth
of Pinterest was driven by marketing
it's a really good article to read into
I'm biased of course
so the first tactic I want to talk about
is internationalization Facebook
internationalized too late
Sheryl said it broadly in public and I
definitely agree with that one of the
biggest barriers to our long term growth
and one of the biggest things we had to
deal with was all the countries where
they were clones famously study felt
said had fake book CSS in their in their
HTML and there were a ton of sites like
that out there whether it was Judy felt
said as a clear clone of contact your
mixi Cyworld Orkut there were all these
different social networks around the
world that grew up while Facebook was
focused on the US and so
internationalizing was an important
barrier we needed to knock down and
knocking down barriers is often very
important to think about for growth
Facebook started off as college only so
every college that it was launched in
was knocking
a barrier when Facebook expanded beyond
colleges to high schools I wasn't at the
company
but that was a company shaking moment
where people questioned whether or not
Facebook could actually survive the
culture of the site could survive then
expanding from high schools to everyone
that was like just before I joined and
that was a shocking moment and that
spurred the growth on to 50 million and
then we hit a brick wall and when we hit
that brick wall that was the point when
a lot of existential questions were
being asked inside Facebook about
whether any social network could ever
get to more than a hundred million users
which sounds stupid now but at the time
no one had ever achieved it everyone had
kind of tapped out between 50 and 100
million users and we were worried that
it wasn't possible and that was the
point at which the growth team got set
up Jim auth brought a bunch of us
together it was he said very publicly
that he wanted to fire me on multiple
occasions and he probably should have
done but without your mouth I think none
of us would have stated the company we
were a really weird bunch of people but
it worked out and the two things we did
I think that really really drove growth
initially was number one we focused on
that 10 friends in 14 days and getting
users to the magic moment and that was
something Zach drove because we were all
stuck in analysis paralysis saying is it
causation is it correlation Zach was
like you really think if no one gets a
friend that they'll be active on
Facebook are you crazy
the second thing was
internationalization it was knocking
down another barrier and when we
launched it I think there were two
things that we did really well number
one was even though we were late and we
were stressed about being late we took
the time to build it in a scalable way
we moved slow to move fast and you can
actually read here the full story from
Naomi and one of the videos links from
the lecture page but what we did was we
wrapped all the strings on the site and
FBT which is our translation script and
then Oryx translation extraction script
and then we created the community
translation platform so that we didn't
just have professional translators
translate in the site we could have all
of our users translate in the site and
we got French translated in 12 hours but
we managed to get to this day we're now
a hundred and four languages translated
by Facebook for Facebook 80 plus 70 of
those are translated
by the community and we took the time to
build something that would enable us to
scale the other thing is we prioritize
the right languages so back then the
right languages the big four languages
were French Italian German and Spanish
fix and Chinese but we were blocked in
China so we focused on French Italian
German and Spanish now look at that list
that's today's distribution of languages
Italian isn't on the list anymore French
and German are about to fall off in the
last year we quadrupled the number of
people on Facebook in Hindi quadrupled
and so building for where the world is
today is an easy mistake to make and
it's what a lot of the other social
networks did we built a scalable
translation infrastructure that actually
enabled us to attack all of the
languages so we could be ready for where
the future is going to is going to be
and you'll probably be able to see some
stuff from our internet 2 org summit in
India about where we want to go with
language translations later today
because I think they're talking about
that stuff there so these are the
tactics I want to go through now and
I'll stick with the whiteboard for that
stuff but I'd really encourage you guys
as I go through these if you've got any
questions about them let me know I think
this should be like a more freeform time
anyway but I think some of these tactics
are quite interesting so virality yes I
think there are two ways to look at
virality there's a great book ah whoops
the book on the right here by Adam
Penenberg viral loop goes through a
bunch of case studies of companies that
have grown through viral marketing and I
strongly encourage you if you're
interested in viral marketing to get
that book
I think overly and advertising is great
as well because chapter 7 he's like if
you can't think of anything else stick a
car to a billboard with superglue and
people who buy your superglue and he's
got some really it's got some really
good creative tips in there lately the
guy's been dead 20 years and I think
he's still iced I by everyone on my team
gets both of these books when they start
on my team so virality so Sean Park has
this model that he taught or he told us
about when he when when I joined
Facebook which is to think about
virality for a product in terms of three
things first is payload
so how many people can you hit with any
given viral blast second he had cooler
words for these I'm not quite as cool
[Music]
second is conversion rate and third is
frequency payload frequency and
conversion rate whatever that wouldn't
so how many people can you hit at once
as payload how many times can you hit
them per blast is frequency and what are
they going to convert that and that
gives you a fundamental idea of how
viral a product is so hotmail is the
like canonical example of brilliant
viral marketing right back when hotmail
launched there are a bunch of male
companies that have been funded and that
were throwing huge amounts of money at
traditional advertising how many people
know the hotmail story virality awesome
great new audience sorry
just two or three people will be bored
but hotmail back in back at that time
people couldn't get free email clients
they had to be tied to their ISP and
hotmail and a few other companies
launched and their clients were
available wherever you went you could
log in via library internet or whatever
school internet and be able to get
access to that which is a really big
value proposition for everyone who
wanted to access it most of the
companies went out there and did big TV
campaigns and billboard campaigns and
newspaper campaigns and things like that
bought a lot of advertising off Yahoo
all of those things but the hotmail team
didn't have as much funding and so they
had to Scrabble around to figure out how
to do it so what they did was add that
little link at the bottom of every email
that said sent from hotmail get your
free email here now the interesting
thing is that meant the payload was low
right you email one person at a time not
necessarily going to have a huge payload
maybe you send around some of those
viral spammy emails but then I'm not
sure I'll click on your link the
frequency is high though because you're
emailing the same people over and over
and over which means you're going to hit
them once twice three times a day with
that same link and really move up the
impressions and the conversion rate was
also very high because people didn't
like being tied to their ISP email
and so hotmail ended up being extremely
viral because it had high frequency and
high conversion rates
another example is PayPal PayPal PayPal
is interesting because PayPal has two
sides to it
PayPal has the buyer and the seller side
the other thing that's interesting about
PayPal is its mechanism for viral growth
was eBay and so you can use all kinds of
things for reality that may not look
necessarily obviously viral so PayPal if
you sent money if you said to a seller I
am going to send you money like I can't
think of a higher conversion rate
frequency was low payload was low but
PayPal did this thing where they gave
away money when you got your friends to
sign up for PayPal and so that's how
they went viral on the consumer side
they didn't have to do that for sellers
because if I said I am gonna send you
money via this you will take that and
even on the consumer side they went
viral because someone said sign up for
this thing and you'll get 10 bucks why
wouldn't you so they were able to go
viral but in both cases it was because
their conversion rate was incredibly
high on the buyer and the seller side
not because their payload in frequency
was high makes sense so this is a really
good way to look at virality if you want
to say is this product viral Facebook
was not viral via email sharing or
anything like that Facebook was purely
viral by a word-of-mouth because the
interesting thing about PayPal and
hotmail is to use them the first person
had to send an email to someone who
wasn't on the service with Facebook
there's no native way to contact people
who aren't on the service and everyone
thinks of Facebook is like viral
marketing success and that's actually
not how it grew it was word-of-mouth by
royalty because it was an awesome
product you wanted to tell your friends
about how's everyone doing is this
interesting great question yes we're
talking about this low payload in both
of the examples in the later rounds as
this sort of campaigner whatever you
want to call it gets going
have a much higher payload as more and
more people are sending hot now more and
more folks in that way your payload
grows and girls and girls so the
question in the first round it makes
sense that it has a low payload but in
later rounds on you're gonna have higher
payloads as people send more and more
and more emails I guess in my head well
first and foremost I think you actually
only send emails to a small number of
people so compared to like the massive
viral engines that exist today where you
import some ones into our contact book
and send them all send them all an email
or where you post to everyone's friends
on Facebook the actual payloads are
still very small even if it's everyone
that you email on a frequent basis you
hit and I'm also thinking really per
female sent out how many people are on
it but it's a fair point like yeah as
more people get on again hotmail they'll
send more emails as more people use
email the product actually grows more
and more successfully so that's affect
fair point
go for it completely agree that's why oh
sorry
dozen points of conversion matter as
well so on hotmail you click to sign up
but on a billboard you have to remember
the URL goes to the website type it in
find the registration button click
register and sign yes yes anything you
can do to move friction out of the flow
and going from an offline ad to an
online ad removes huge amounts of
friction from the flow obviously totally
agree with that one more at the back on
frequency and conversion regulators
absolutely if you hit someone with the
same promotion I owe everything to that
aren't frequency in conversion rate
related if you hit someone with the same
email over and over and over again or
the same banner ad this is one of the
things that's fundamental about online
marketing the same rules apply to every
channel if you hit someone with the same
Facebook ad over and over and over the
more times you hit them with the same ad
the less they'll click that's why we
have like creative exhaustion you have
to rotate creatives on Facebook same
with banner ads same with newsfeed
stories the 50th time you see that IQ
story in your newsfeed you are not going
to click on it if you haven't clicked on
the 49 before you're not going to click
on the 50th the same is absolutely true
with these emails so if you send the
same email over and over and over to
people for an invite then or if you send
the same little link at the bottom over
and over and over to people for hotmail
or I mean the paper one's different cuz
people just signed up but yes you will
get lower conversion rate and that
impress the more you hit someone with
the same message the less they convert
is fundamental across every online
marketing channel every online marketing
channel cool second way to look at
virality which i think is awesome is by
this guy ed and Ed runs the growth team
at uber now he was at the growth team at
Facebook and he was a Stanford MBA
student did a class similar to this
where they talked about virality and
they all went and built viral products
and there was there was a bunch of press
about that actually and he's brilliant
of this stuff the interesting thing
about uber is if you look at their
growth team they're incredibly focused
on drivers because there's a two-sided
marketplace they need drivers that's a
huge huge chunk of their focus as a team
even though they've got like probably
the best viral guy in the world at the
company
so with virality you send out you get
someone to contact import let's say then
the question is how many of those people
do you get to send imports then the
question is - how many people then how
many click and you can put extra steps
in this you could put how many open how
many click whatever how many click how
many sign up and then how many of those
import so essentially you want people
who sign up to your site to import their
contacts you want to then get them to
send an invite to all of those contacts
you want to get it to all of those
contacts not just one of them then you
want to get up sent those to click and
I've sent those sign up if you multiply
out the percents at every point in this
this is essentially where well this
isn't a percent this is a number if you
multiply us out that's essentially the
point where you get to the question of
what is the k-factor
so if you have when someone imports if
on average they send invites to a
hundred people sorry doing that wrong
let's say a hundred people get an invite
per person who input imports and then of
those 10% click that gets you to ten and
then of those let's say 50% sign up
that gets you to five and then of those
only ten to twenty percent actually
subsequently import you're going to be
at a point where you're at point five to
one as your k factor and you're going to
not be viral so a lot of things like
vidi are very good a pump it or were
very good at pumping out stories that
got the K factor over one and it's
perfectly doable to get the K factor
over one but if you have something that
doesn't have high retention on the back
end it doesn't really matter so you
should look at your invite flow and say
okay what is my equivalent of import how
many people per import or invite sent to
how many of those receive clicks how
many of those convert to my site how
many of those then import to get an idea
of your k factor but the really
important thing is still to think about
retention and not to think about viral T
and only do this after after you have a
large number of people retained on your
product per person who signs up so a
couple more things we were going to
touch on SEO email SMS and push
notifications so on SEO there are three
things you need to think about first one
is keyword research people do this badly
all the time so I launched this cocktail
site they talked to you about I spent a
year optimizing it to rank for the word
cocktail making turns out in the UK no
one searches for cocktail making about
500 people a month I dominated that
search time it was awesome four hundred
visitors a month that's amazing
everyone searches for cocktail recipes
in the UK and in the US which is the
biggest market everyone searches for
drink recipes so I optimized for the
wrong word so you've got to do your
research first about what you're going
to go after so research consists of what
do people search for that's related to
your site how many people search for it
how many other people are ranking for it
and how valuable is it for you
supply demand and value simple economics
I guess so you do your keyword research
you figure out which keywords you want
to rank for there are great tools out
there to enable you to do that
honestly the best is quite often the
Google Adwords Keyword planner tool
really once you've done that the next
most important thing is
so PageRank is how all of SEO
essentially is driven and Google is
based on Authority now there's a lot of
other things in Google's algorithm now
like do people search for your website
there's a lot of stuff about the
distribution of what the anchor text is
there's sent to your site so that if you
abuse it and spam it they can pop up
with spam white on a white background
five pages below the fold doesn't work
anymore but the single most important
thing is to get valuable links from high
authority websites for you to ranking
google most important thing then you
need to distribute that love inside your
site by internally linking effectively
and when I joined Facebook we'd launched
SEO in September 2007 which was before I
joined I joined November 2007 and we'd
launched and we were getting no traffic
from the the pages we'd launched public
user profiles so when I went in and
looked at it the only way you could get
to any public user profile was to click
on the footer of the page for the about
link then click on one of the blog
articles then click on one of the
authors and then spider out through
their friends to get to all their
friends turns out that Google was like
they've buried these pages they're not
very valuable I'm not going to rank them
we made one change we added a directory
so the Google could quickly get to every
page on the site and we hundred access
Co traffic very very simple change to
have a lot of upside about distributing
the link love internally and then the
last thing is there's a bunch of table
stakes stuff XML sitemaps making sure
you have the right headers it's all
covered really well I'm lying for what
you want to do I'm gonna stop now and
make sure because we had a few questions
but what other questions are there go
for it let's go into email okay great
email email is dead for people under 25
in my opinion right young people don't
use email they use whatsapp they use SMS
they use snapchat they use Facebook they
don't use email if you're targeting an
older audience email is pretty
successful email still works for
distribution but realistically email is
not that great for teenagers especially
an even people University you know how
much you use instant messaging apps and
how little you use email and you guys
are probably on the high end
the scale for email because you're in
Silicon Valley that being said on email
the things to think about email SMS and
push notifications all behave the same
way they all have questions of
deliverability so to finish first first
you have to finish your email has to get
to someone's inbox so if you send a lot
of spam and you end up with dirty IPS or
you send spam from shared servers where
other people are sourced you send email
notifications from shared servers where
other people are sending spam from you
are going to end up being put in the
spam folder consistently and your email
will fail completely you may end up
being blocked and have your email
bounced there's a lot of stuff around
email where you have to look when you
receive feedback from the servers you
are sending email two 500-series errors
versus 400-series errors you have to be
respectful of how those are handled if
someone gives you a hard bounce retry
once or twice and then stop trying
because if you are someone who abuses
people's inboxes the email companies
spam folder you and it's very hard to
get out if you get caught on a spam
house link or anything like that it's
very hard to get out it's really
important with email that you are a high
class citizen that you do good work with
email because you want to have
deliverability for the long run that
counts for push notifications and SMS to
with SMS you can go on by SMS traffic
via gray routes with people where
they're having earphones strung up
attached to like a computer and pumping
out sms's that works for a time but it
always gets shut down and I've seen so
many companies make these mistakes where
they think they're going to grow by
using these kind of tactics if you can't
get your email your SMS or your push
delivered you will never get any success
from these push you spam your power
users I know that's slightly different I
said earlier but you actually spam your
power users and give them notifications
they don't care about and make it really
hard for them to opt out so there's no
settings where they can opt out and they
start blocking you you can never push
them once they've opted out of your push
notifications and it's very hard
actually to prompt them to turn them on
once they've turned them off so number
one thing to think about about email SMS
and push notifications is you have to
get them delivered beyond that it's a
question of open
a click-through rate so what is the
compelling subject line you can put
there so that people are going to open
your email and how can you get them to
click when they visit everyone focuses
towards doing marketing emails that are
just spam in my opinion newsletters are
stupid don't do newsletters because
you'll send the same message to everyone
on your site
someone who signed up to your site
yesterday versus someone who's been
using your product for three years do
they need the same message no the most
effective email you can do is
notifications so what are you sending
what should you be notifying people off
and this is a great place where we're in
the wrong mindset as a Facebook user
I don't want Facebook to email me about
every like I receive because I receive a
lot of likes because I've got a bunch of
Facebook friends but as a new Facebook
user that first like you receive as a
magic moment turning on that
notification across all of our channels
increased the click-through rate on our
emails SMS and push notifications but we
only turned it on for low engaged users
who weren't coming back to the site so
it wouldn't be spamming for them
spamming them so it was a great
experience so think about that
what notifications should you be sending
is the first thing that you need to
think about on email SMS and push and
then the second thing you need to be
thinking about is how can you create
great triggered marketing campaigns so
when someone created their first cross
border trade transaction was one of the
best email campaigns I was ever part of
an eBay in terms of click-through rates
it was awesome because it was really
timely really in context the right thing
to do for the user so I'd say make sure
you have deliverability most important
thing focus on notifications and trigger
based email SMS and push notifications
beyond that so I think we're out of time
there's one thing I wanted to finish
with which is and if you guys have any
questions I guess like you can reach me
and if I get spammed I just won't reply
we have great spam filters snow my only
favorite quotes is from General Patton
and it's so cliched it's crazy but it's
awesome a good plan violently executed
today is better than a perfect plan
tomorrow and one of the things Chamath
instilled in us and javi
still instills is us and mark instills
across the whole of Facebook is this
move fast and don't be afraid to break
stuff ethos if you can run more
experiments than the next guy if you can
be hungry for growth if you fight and
die for every extra user and you stay up
late at night to get those extra users
to run those experiments to get the data
and do it over and over and over again
you will grow faster Marcus said he
thinks we won because we wanted it more
and I really believe that we just worked
really hard it's not like we're crazy
smart or we've all done these crazy
things before we just worked really
really hard and we executed fast and I
strongly encourage you to do that growth
is optional thank you
[Applause]
you